foreign
let's go to Patrick in Salem
Virginia what's up Patrick
hey John thank you for having me on you
got it man thanks for hanging out you
get to you get to see all the sausages
made if you if you call into the show
and just we put you on hold for a while
or we I think we called you and put you
on hold for a while you get to hear what
a disaster I am behind the scenes right
oh it's all good thank you thank
goodness for editing right oh you have
no idea man you have no idea
um so what's up
um so my question is um how do I have a
healthy relationship with work
and uh there's a kind of a long
backstory to that that we can kind of
dig through a little bit but uh
long story short I tend to get into this
cycle where I'm super excited about a
job I love the new career opportunity
and then like
six months into it I'm like yeah this is
awful I don't like this anymore and then
I get burned out
um
frustrated and then I tap out and leave
um I'm really tired of that cycle and I
wanna break out of it but I don't really
know how oh man
how old are you I'm 26.
okay
this is one of those rare moments in my
life when I get to talk to 26 year old
me
okay
and I have
oh my gosh man I can get pretty
emotional about this
um
I'm gonna give you like a conversation
direct from my heart is that cool
yep that works for me because I'm
talking to myself at 26.
26 is when I got my
um first big fancy job at a university
and I think it was three or four months
in then I started applying for another
job and then for another one and then
for another one and then I got so
obsessed with applying for other jobs
and then I finally got one
and then I got there and within five to
six months I was already applying for
something else and then I was looking
for something else I was looking for
something else right and then I ended up
imploding
in counseling we call it the tyranny of
accomplishing all of your dreams
and the problem is you were looking for
somewhere something
to make you feel like you are worth
being alive and that thing doesn't exist
whether that's a new romantic partner
well that's a new car whether it's a new
job
and you show up with the best of
intentions because this is going to be
the one and you get after it and you
realize right when you get there that
you went with you
right yeah yep and you get bored and you
get annoyed
and so tell me if I'm wrong here and man
feel free to tell me I'm wrong
here was my special gift you ready
I would get bored I would not not bored
that's not right I would get
disillusioned
I thought it would feel different making
x amount of dollars I thought it would
feel different having such and such
title I thought it would feel different
having these type of meetings or being
included at this level instead of that
level right yeah and so what I would do
is
I would begin to slowly make the people
around me my enemy
and I would get annoyed by their jokes
that weren't very funny or I would find
one little place where I thought I
wouldn't handle it like that I would do
it like this or if there was I wouldn't
say a moral black and white failure
there's all obviously those but they're
Gray
and I would make the gray super black
and white so that I could begin to
create space giving me permission to
leave with my head held high because I
am this martyr here making this big
right decision and I'm out of here and
I'm going to the next thing
yep you must have had somebody following
me for the last six years because that's
pretty much exactly it no I'm just
recounting my life I'm recounting my
life
so
there's a couple of things at play here
but
ultimately it starts with an identity
shift
okay here's a couple of the major
identity shifts I'm gonna make one of
them came from a mentor of mine
um I consider him one of the smartest
most brilliant wise Minds I've ever had
the opportunity to be in contact with
and he was a I'd consider him a
spiritual Mentor he's someone I have
gone to in the past for a quandaries
about ethical and moral decisions in my
life
he posed this question one time and it
was it was kind of like a dagger to me
he said what if you lived your life like
you would never move
like you couldn't ever move
what conversations would you have then
what
um
what would you do to improve the
relationships in your life what would
you do to change the way you presented
yourself at work and in your marriage
and in your neighborhood
because if we are at your church right
because if it's always like I don't like
it I'm out of here
um then we are never going to be settled
and so when I took this job my current
one I made a choice I'm gonna be here
and so I can honestly say for the first
time in my life I have not applied for
another job since I've been here
okay right it's a choice I mean it's an
identity I'm gonna be here now there may
come a day when I gotta go or I get more
likely I get asked to leave
um but
I am I am going to put both of my feet
here and what that's meant is I've had
to seek validation
seek well-being seek Wellness elsewhere
that means that I've had to make peace
with me and that has sucked and that has
meant I've had to have some very
difficult and challenging conversations
with my wife
I've had to become a different Dad I've
had to go to counseling I've had a coach
that I've met with regularly just to
walk through different decisions and
thought processes
I've had to really become laser
disciplined with my exercise and diet
I've had to do a lot of internal work
and make some major changes in my life
um I've had to really get serious about
my spiritual life I've had to just make
some internal changes because I'm not
relying on some external job to try to
make me whole because it can't do that
does that make sense
that makes perfect sense so what job are
you doing right now
um So currently I'm a package handler
for uh for FedEx okay and um tomorrow I
start orientation for a checker position
at a Coca-Cola oh so you've already quit
that job and you're on to the next
um it's it's a part-time job so it's not
paying me enough to uh to pay the
mortgage so I gotta yeah do something
else
um
are you married so yeah I'm I am married
yes you have little ones uh no kids yet
has your wife started getting that
exhale when you come home with a new
scheme or a new plan or a new reason why
you got to leave this job
um we haven't hit that point yet with
this job
um no no I'm talking about she's been
with you for six years
oh yeah yeah no that was a kind of a big
big conversation we were having about a
year and a half ago let me tell you why
that's devastating this is devastating
to her I don't want to guilty or shame
you but I just want to paint you a
bigger picture because right now all
you're doing is staring at your belly
button and I know because I was there
she's also wondering what about me
when does he wake up and get bored with
me
when does he wake up and decide he needs
another one of me too
and if you're being honest
you've had that thought as well
and she can feel it on you foreign
okay I'll give you that one but you know
um
I didn't realize
how unsettled how every time my wife
started to put roots in the ground I
would cut I would sever them
and for me looking for another job
looking for another place looking for
the opportunity with sport
for her it was just ripping the plant
out of the pot again ripping the plant
out of the pot again I didn't realize
how hard her heart was pumping every day
just to try to have some semblance of
normalcy because she didn't know where
her flighty
flaky husband was gonna drag her off to
next
either emotionally or spiritually or
actually like let's move this from this
city and go somewhere else
and so
that same thing I'm putting out on on
your wife that I I did to my wife
it's happening to you too
and so the first thing what you do is to
resettle your identity I'm going to be a
guy who sticks around
I'm going to be a guy that uses that all
that energy to I'm out of here I'm
looking for a new job I'm going to use
that energy to be the best freaking
employee in this whole company
I'm going to work to satisfy this
Mission and try that for six months
go all in this company went all in on
you go all in back give them that much
dignity and respect for six months and
see if it doesn't change your entire
well-being and
if you've created a life for yourself
that you can't afford whether it's a
mortgage whether it's car payments
whether it's whatever it is your body is
going to respond anxiously all of the
time and you're going to be trying to
solve that anxiety everywhere have you
done that
yeah I I get into that um I get into
those thought processes and it's like oh
I could start this business or I'm like
constantly looking for stuff on the side
of the road that I can pick up and sell
for 20 bucks and but is that because
you've created a life for yourself that
you can't afford
we we can afford our um our lifestyle uh
the the mortgage is really the only debt
that we have I'm still paying off a
little bit of school from when I got my
my CDL license
um but as far as like we're going to
lose everything in the next 30 days if I
don't get a paycheck um it's not quite
to that point
okay that means your body is running hot
right now trying to keep you guys safe
so I want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you for free one year of
Ramsay plus that's my parent company
that's the where I work here and we're
gonna I'm gonna give you all the lessons
to pay off all those debts but more
importantly to give you and your wife an
Avenue for conversation about who you're
going to be as a couple how you're going
to spend money how you're going to
budget how you're going to work together
and
that when you when you go through a
process just how are we going to spend
our money
how are we going to join bank accounts
if you haven't done that already that
happens today
how do we become one in this deal then
you have to start planning about what
tomorrow looks like when you start
planning about what tomorrow looks like
you have to decide things like what job
are you going to do and where are you
going to work and who do you want to be
and what do you want to do does that
make sense
yep that makes perfect you guys got to
have those conversations your wife
deserves some stability man and you do
too yeah
and
what's your long-term play man what do
you want to do what were you what what's
your purpose who do you want to serve
oh ultimately I want to serve my Creator
and my savior
um that's my number one goal but what
does that look like as a job
I have not a clue I've done I worked in
the golf industry as a golf professional
I've worked as a Mason I've worked as an
electrician I was a truck driver I've
been all over the map and
I barely know which way is up and in
regards to a career Okay and like I'm
just trying to pay the bills right now
that's right that's right
what's underneath that
a lot of fear a fear of what
not being good enough
who told you that
I don't know who told me you do who was
it say it out loud
it's kind of crazy to say but my
kindergarten teacher was kind of a
the first person that ever even planted
that thought in my head and I've just
been repeating it over and over for the
last 21 years how did Mom and Dad
contribute to that
foreign
and I never really felt celebrated for
the little Winds of getting better at
something okay
as a kid you should have got that
and I'm not saying your dad's a bad guy
I'm saying your dad did that no no he's
not he didn't have that tool in his tool
kit and my guess is he was trying to
push you because he wanted you to become
a great man and often men pushing other
men to become great men forget that you
can only become great
when the bottom rungs of the needs the
hierarchy of needs are met which are
safety and relationships right then you
when you are anchored in there's a
reason they send you to boot camp
um in our in the Army in the military
so that you can learn to follow rules
and you learn to work as a team because
only then can you go do great things
right yeah
so those things happened and here you
are
now you're gonna have to decide to do is
to get a group of guys are you lonely as
I'll get out too
yeah yeah um yep yep so
you have to make a conscious Choice I'm
ending I'm gonna stop being lonely
I'm gonna get with a group of guys
whether I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
invite a group of randos out from work
from my church from the neighborhood I
don't care
I'm gonna have a barbecue at my house
and everyone's just gonna be invited
over I don't care how this looks you're
gonna have to get radical about that the
same as people get about losing weight
same as they get about exercise programs
as quit and drinking you're gonna have
to decide to quit being lonely
with a radical move okay
okay
and I want you and your wife to sit down
and say and I want you to tell her I
understand that I have given you a life
that lacks stability
and my promise is I'm gonna start
working to heal from the inside out not
from the outside in
and you are probably gonna see her
exhaling away you haven't seen in a long
time because here's what I guarantee
she's done she's created a cocoon of the
world for her to exist in where it's
safe because you're not
and your body senses that you are not
connected and it is trying to solve that
because it is anxious anxious anxious
anxious anxious
right yeah that's yeah that's spot on
okay so we're gonna we're going to
take a knee
this is submission and all you by the
way pause real quick here Patrick all
you idiots out there who are like what
here is a simp or whatever that's
supposed to be shut up shut up
some of the most bold
masculine things you can do is to take a
knee in front of your wife and say I've
screwed this up or I've been trying to
solve this problem this way and it's not
working and I've left you completely
isolated alone I'm sorry
I'm committed to learning new skills
and skill number one is I'm going to
learn to be at peace with myself skill
number one two is I'm going to learn to
learn to live in stability I've never
had it before
is that cool Patrick yep that that
sounds good okay also I want you to stay
on the line my friend Ken Coleman who is
a career Guru has a career assessment
I'm gonna send it to you for free I'm
gonna send you a code online I want you
to take it okay oh I actually I actually
did take that um
okay and um did it help yeah
it did help
um it helped clarify some of the the
underlying frustrations that I've found
with okay those particular jobs very
cool well then I'll do this I'll send
you I'm gonna send you a copy of
paycheck to purpose his book and I want
you to read through that and also send
you his other book too I'm sending you
everything
um proximity principle and that will
walk you through here's where we go next
but that is for you to read and Ponder
and read with your wife and get some
feedback get some friends who will speak
into your life before I took this job I
flew to Texas and met with some of my
oldest friends in the world because I I
get I get emotional I get anxious I get
wound up
and a good leader which is I'm trying to
lead a business I'm trying to lead my
units I'm trying to lead my family
um or co-lead my family with my wife
like a good leader takes feedback and
wisdom especially in the fog of War I
flew to Texas met with some friends and
I asked them hey I've been working for
20 years to get to this one one place in
my career and I finally got there I'm
thinking about quitting it to go be a
YouTuber
and I took their wisdom and they all
laughed and smiled and opened a drink
and we talked and cracked up and then
they said hey this sounds crazy and this
sounds right
and that's what I needed I needed some
perspective and some sobriety
not literal sobriety but sobriety so
once you get some friends and have those
conversations about work and purpose and
value
but you're not going to find it man
someone's going to bring you in and pay
you a million dollars
and call you CEO
and you're still going to look in the
mirror and see that Kindergarten kid
whose teacher said you'll never amount
to crap
or you'll still see that seventh grader
who gets so excited that you got an 88
on that math test that you busted your
butt for and your dad says wow would
have killed you to get two more points
you could get an A
are always just going to be a b student
until you let that kid be free my kid's
gonna be trying to solve the problems
man
and money and titles won't fix that
start with your home start with your
wife start your relationship start with
y'all's identity
start with you deciding you want to be
well
and man you got a whole Runway ahead of
you
into a radical new life it's going to be
incredible